Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and Marvel just
confirmed it was going to release the first
Ant Man trailer during the Agent Carter Premiere
on Tuesday.
They will post it online after the tv show,
so no worries on missing it.
I know there are some issues with international
people finding ways to watch the show.
This is going to be a breakdown of the tiny
Trailer footage they posted and my top 5 ant-man
stories.
Important stuff, in case you had trouble seeing
the tiny footage, I tried to blow it up a
little.
It’s just shots of each of the main characters.
That’s it.
You see Paul Rudd as Scott Lang getting hauled
away by the law.
He’s a thief in the comics and those skills
are going to be key to the plot of this movie.
Corey Stoll as we see here plays Darren Cross,
he’s the villain of the film.
He bogarts Hank Pym’s technology, to create
his own shrinking suit and call himself Yellowjacket.
They just released high res promo art for
it.
All I’m wondering is what he does with those
extra arms.
A lot of you were asking me about the Yellowjacket
name because Hank Pym in the comics was Yellowjacket
for a while.
Yes, that’s true, the movie is changing
the backstory.
In the comics Darren Cross had his own competing
company that went up against Stark Industries,
Trask Industries and Oscorp.
Eventually he started to die, performed crazy
surgery and as a result of a transplant, mutated
and got minor powers.
The character did cross over with the Scott
Lang Ant-Man when he was trying to find the
doctor that performed Cross’ life saving
surgery so she could do the same thing for
his daughter who was also dying.
The movie is downplaying some of the Scott
Lang comic book backstory, but he still has
a daughter.
If you’ve read the comic, just expect some
minor changes.
Hank Pym of course is played by Michael Douglas,
watching him old mansplain the movie at comic
con was the most fun things ever.
There was also that cherry popping moment.
Here’s the clip of that in case you didn’t
see it.
(ant man comic con clip)
I posted the whole Ant-Man comic con Panel
and avengers too so if you want to watch those
again I’ll add links in the description
below.
He enlists Scott Lang to help take down Darren
Cross and get his Pym Tech back.
For those wondering about Edgar Wright’s
version of the movie, in his version Scott
Lang was working at Hank Pym’s company as
a scientist.
It didn’t involve the thief aspects of his
backstory as much.
This version of the story plays a little more
on that, and Scott Lang isn’t quite as much
of a Tony Stark type person.
He’s more average joe who gets swept up
in the heist adventure.
We also see Hope Van Dyne, played by Evangeline
Lily.
She’s also a big part of Team Pym in the
movie.
Her mother is Janet Van Dyne, but in all of
the interviews everyone has done.
They never mention Janet.
So by all accounts, she’s probably not in
the movie in a big way.
But she’ll probably be mentioned when Hank
and Hope have father daughter scenes.
I think we all just really want to know if
Hope is going to take the mantle from her
mother and become The Wasp.
There was a story arc in the comics where
an alternate universe version of Hope named
Hope Pym became Red Queen, but she was kind
of a villain.
So, just another small change to the comics.
That’s pretty much it for the footage, the
full trailer next week will have a ton more
footage.
I’ll do a full breakdown.
So be sure to subscribe to get it.
It’s probably the weirdest movie Marvel
has done so far next to Guardians of the Galaxy.
I think it was more of a comedy when Edgar
Wright was working on it and they wanted the
tone to be more in line with the other marvel
films.
Edgar Wright has a very awesome personal style
to the way his films look and it’s easy
to understand how trying to fit that into
the Marvel system was hard.
The new director Peyton Reed, isn’t really
known for doing bigger action films like this.
His most recent work has been TV Work like
New Girl.
But he also did Upright Citizens Brigade which
I love, Mr Show on HBO and Weird Al Yankovic’s
tv show.
So they wouldn’t have hired him to do the
movie if they didn’t want Ant-Man to be
a comedy.
Just think of it as Marvel’s first Comedy.
Guardians of The Galaxy is a very funny movie,
but I don’t consider it as a comedy.
It’s an action movie that’s also very
funny.
I think Ant-Man will feel like a comedy with
a lot of action in it.
If you’re confused about where this fits
in with the other movies.
Ant Man is now the final movie in Phase 2.
When they first announced it, it was supposed
to be the first movie in Phase 3.
But I think because they changed their minds
on the direction they wanted to take, they
decided to fit it in more with what’s been
going on between the first Avengers Movie
and Avengers 2.
By all accounts, just assume what’s going
on in the movie is going on around the same
time things in Avengers 2 are happening.
Once they start doing press for
the movie they’ll explain the timeline better.
I wanted to talk about my favorite Ant-Man
stories, but this video got way too long.
So I’ll just do a separate video for my
TOP 5 after the trailer drops.
Marvel is releasing a brand new Scott Lang
Ant Man comic written by Nick Spencer on,
surprise surprise, January 7, next wednesday.
The day after they post the trailer for the
movie.
It’s supposed to be just as awesome as Matt
Fraction’s run on Hawkeye, so you should
definitely check it out.
Here’s some of the preview pages.
It looks like he’s going to be working at
Stark Industries.
Actually, you know what, I think I’ll give
away gift cards for comixology so people who
win can buy the comic.
Would you guys rather I start doing stuff
like that in my giveaways?
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on my ant man trailer
video next week.
I’ll remind everyone when I post my video
so no worries.